Walter sure that there was adequate
funding for the conference expenses
acted as the sort of chief contact in
communicating with people in Ukraine who
from our perspective were a little
difficult to reach sometimes by email or
by phone Walter did all of that
yesterday he organized the very nice
meeting at New York University and
without Walter this conference probably
would have had a very different image
Walter thank you very much and finally
of course I'd like to thank our renowned
speakers whom you will be listening to
today each of them will be introduced by
their panel chairs I'm sure that there
will be plenty to talk about today and
tomorrow today of course being the more
historical side of what we want to do
and tomorrow a little bit more
contemporary some of the topics that you
will be hearing about and I hope that
you will be reacting to and asking
questions about in making comments about
our how poles and Cossacks viewed each
other and musket be in the old days how
they made choices and how historians
view those choices today the historical
forces at work during World War one and
the ways in which relations between the
two peoples evolved during the interwar
period the tragedy of World War two and
it's aftermath for both Poland and
Ukraine when massacres of innocent
populations and individuals became an
instrument of policy by governments in
those those countries we will also be
talking about the contacts and
discussions between Ukrainian and polish
intellectuals during and after the thaw
and through the Solidarity period the
successes that the Ukrainian and polish
elites have achieved over the last
decade in various areas and the
challenges that they face today and
perhaps also a forecast of the future
and what remains to be done to
truly fulfill the spirit of the
strategic partnership that exists
between the two neighbors in the context
of NATO enlargement and a changing
global security architecture in the
context of European integration and also
rapid economic change particularly these
days in Ukraine I encourage you all to
take a look at the exhibits that are
located in the lobby and I welcome you
all to what will be a stimulating
session we hope that this will be the
precursor of future meetings like this
in Poland and Ukraine if we can get the
funding to do this sort of thing yeah
kyojin quia thank you very much now I
would like to ask professor me how abou
Huff's key of Adam it's kovitch
university and the audrina university to
introduce our first panel and as i said
before professor Lahav ski is the
question school foundation semper
Polonia foundation distinguished
visiting professor in Polish studies and
under his iron rule we will make sure
that we don't overstep our boundaries
right me how thank you
that one
and first of course i would like to
advise our speakers for this
sisson is having on university in cattle
in the music google cloud service in
moscow on at stanford university
received his PhD at London University in
1966 sciences and running university who
migrated to the United States in 1969
since 1970 lecture at Columbia
University here is working and since
1992 physical fessor of history
georgetown university
it wasn't in control at Berkeley
University University of people can
worsen University were semester polish
coming on the Polish commonwealth
central city office love the sixteenth
and seventeenth century data I wish
Sarah books among them republic vs
accomplices part between Russia 1686
1697 published in nineteen ninety three
and four days book he was awarded Oscar
galaxies price since 1997 is over
of Sciences a speaker will be present
and season